the crypto creep is ready to cash in on
the on the story of his massive fraud
Hollywood style while on house arrest
disgraced FTX founder Sam bankman freed
reportedly just met with a guy behind
the big short as well as other big
blockbuster movies no word yet on
whether proceeds from any book or movie
deal will go to the millions of people
Sam scammed the liberal media is also
trying to rehab Sam's image already the
New York Times still doing puff pieces
lamenting that his arrest is going to
get this hurt the Bahamas quote in the
U.S Sam Bateman freed is persona non
grata but in interviews across the
Bahamas
residents say that his crimes were
hardly comparable to the gang violence
of the island and expressed fears of
economic Fallout if crypto investors
don't return Tyrus what do you make of
this I'm not making any of it I would
wob that up and throw it in the trash
can like this dude is going to go to
jail but here's the deal he has that
golden carrot people don't believe he
doesn't really not have money and so
when people in his position even the
smartest of people will dumb down just
to get a piece of that so many people
are connected they represent he gave
free money to just about anybody who was
anyone anywhere so he's gonna have a lot
of allies especially they don't want
they also want to know what he's going
to say so of course he's going to make a
move he's going to meet but this guy
just needs to shut up if he had if his
lawyer had any sense to be like stop
doing movie deals every time the good
news is for everyone he heard every time
he talks he digs a deeper hole so of
course they're going to miss him the
residents of the Bahamas going to miss
him because he spent a lot of money
there he brought a lot of money in their
their economy is based off tourism and
when you have people who spend
frivolously like that that's a good
thing for them so yeah they're everyone
who's not affected by him whose bank
accounts aren't empty are going to be
empathetic because he could possibly
help them Katie he brings up a good
point this puff piece is it's outlandish
but one of the things they say is they
say because he spent money on charities
in the Bahamas somehow that that I guess
writes the ship for defrauding people
out of life-saving well just like
because he was donating millions of
dollars to Democrats right and that they
were an ESG friendly company and blah
blah blah therefore they were getting a
free pass on all the fraud that they
were they were conducting but there's a
lot here that the mainstream media could
investigate there's a treasure Trove of
information that investigative reporters
could dive into and yet it's not on the
front page of every single newspaper in
this country a lot of this doesn't make
sense it doesn't add up in terms of the
money Sam bakeman freed is staying at
home and his parents multi-million
dollar home there are allegations that
they were in on this they were deeply
embedded with the Democratic party in
Academia we saw that he had bail of 250
million dollars after saying he only had
a hundred thousand dollars in his bank
account we know that he was PRI flying
private and in the lounge at the airport
when he was supposed to be you know not
in prison and let out of jail and
extradited to the United States and so
there's a lot of questions about where
this money is whether he still is using
money that he defrauded from these
customers and now there's been this
lawsuit filed from FTX customers and
Almeida research customers saying we
want our money back and because his you
know co-founders the people he worked
with have already pled guilty to fraud
the question is how is he still
continuing to be this outlandish with
his spending and being involved in pop
culture and benefiting from the fraud
while other people have already pledged
guilty Rachel his parents are spending I
think ten thousand dollars a week their
Stanford University professors I I have
not worked in Academia I don't know they
make that kind of money why aren't their
assets under scrutiny if not Frozen as
well so first of all regarding the puff
piece if you steal billions of dollars
from average Americans you are not a
celebrity you are very criminal and yet
this guy is being treated like a
celebrity and I believe something is
going on here he knows that he's not in
trouble the way he's acting he knows
he's not in trouble he knows
um that he's being protected by some
very powerful people and so the question
then becomes why what's going on here I
have a theory I've had a lot of tin you
know what do they call it when you tin
foil had theories that have all come
true after covid
um it could be that this guy is meant to
create so much doubt in crypto right
that it would make it easier for our
governments to usher in the digital
dollar which as you know is a powerful
tool to control people I believe that is
the precursor for a chinese-style social
credit score system which I believe
we've already seen elements of that
before Richard I don't know where you
are on sale you think I'm crazy no I
don't I don't I don't think I don't know
anything about crypto so I don't mess
with it
I'll put my money in glasses
I'll put my money in land right Richard
don't know where you are on Sam Bateman
free but what is the incentive for this
like a front of of defense that he's
getting from media so look I think Sam
bankman freed should be behind bars I
don't think he should be under house
arrest I think he committed major fraud
and I and to be honest I think the
government failed on getting him sooner
I think this is a lack of oversight a
lack of Greater transparency and a lack
of actual consumer protection now with
that being said if you read this piece
by the New York Times what they talk
about regarding the Bahamas specifically
it's important to give that some
perspective the Bahamas is a country
that benefits off of Tourism so the idea
that sandbankment was bringing in these
folks that were spending millions of
dollars in that country is the reason we
liked him he spent money here this is
great for our economy so I think you
have to put that on the shelf and say
now and it's also worth pointing out
that in the Bahamas you're not allowed
to buy cryptocurrency they have better
regulatory control over crypto than we
have in the United States so maybe we
should copy and paste their crypto
policy here and maybe Sam Raymond free
would not have been able to take they
should be able to buy whatever we want
yeah yeah but here's the problem now
here imagine we'll buy whatever you want
when he's when you could steal defraud
millions
millions of dollars well you said the
right word though it's about
transparency yeah and that's what the
government should have been doing here
but sadly we haven't regulated crypto
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else